ابناء الاقليات ينتصرون على افلام هوليود
تقليديه في سباق اوسكار مره اخرى بعد
انجاز باراسايت التاريخي في 2020
الفنانه الماليزيه التي جسدت دوره امريكيه
من اصل صيني في فيلم
فازت بافضل ممثله عن دور رئيس لتكون اول
اسيويه تحقق هذا الانجاز كما فاز فينها
بست جوائز اخرى من اصل 11 ترشح لها في حين
افلام هوليود اعلى تقييما خلال العام
الماضي مثل البس وفيلم ستيفنز في البرج
وايضا فيلم الذي ترشح لسبع جوائز اوسكار
عادوا الى منازلهم بلا جائزه واحده في
المرتبه الثانيه جاء الفيلم الالماني كل
شيء هادئ على الجبهه الغربيه الذي فاز
باربع جواز اما اغنيه ناتشو ناتشو في فيلم
ار ار الهندي في حازت على جائزه افضل
اغنيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الاستوديو تنظمي الينا مديره مكتب العربيه
في واشنطن نورتنا في الاستوديو اهلا بك
سعادتنا صباح الخير
[ضحك]
نتحدث اليوم عن الاقليات الاوسكار كراسه
حضور الاقليات وانتصر لخارج هوليود لانه
نتحدث عن الاقليات اليوم في هوليود في
تغيير كبير سهام في المجتمع الامريكي من
ناحيه سيسياسيه ومن ناحيه اجتماعيه اذا
بتلاحظي اذا بدك نبدا بالاجتماعيه لانه
بنحكي على اوسكار والافلام والى اخره
لاحظنا من فتره كان في شكوى انه الافلام
اللي بتفوز عاده هي افلام بتسيطر عليها
الممثلين المعروفين اللي هم بيض اذا اردت
بين قوسين هذا هو التصنيف العرقي
بالولايات المتحده الاقليات صار لهم كثير
دور بارز على كل الاصعده وبالتالي ينعكس
هذا بالافلام بالسينما وحتى احيانا
بتلاقيه على حساب الجوده يعني احيانا بكون
الفيلم مش بيستحق يعني انه بالفعل يوصل
للمرتبه الاولى لكن بيعطوا اياها كتشجيع
كاعتراف كاعاده حق اذا اردتي فهذا في
ظاهره اكيد موجوده وعم تترسخ هذا في
الاجتماعي اليوم اذا ما تحدثنا في الشق
السياسي نادي هل الاهتمام ودعم الاقليات
مرتبط بالاغلبيه الحاكمه اليوم سواء
جمهوريين ديمقراطيين هم ديمقراطيين في
جمهوريين لانه عاده الحزب الجمهوري متهم
انه يعادل اقليات حتى القاعده تبعته مش من
الاقليات الديمقراطيين هم اللي بشجعوا في
عهد الرئيس بايدن يعني لاحظنا تغيير كتير
كتير كبير
وهذا التغيير بتشوفيه بالنسبه للمناصب
يعني الرئيس بيحرص دائما والها بتتذكروا
ايام الانتخابات كنا نحكي طول الوقت انه
رح يعين اول اول اول امراه كانت متحدثه
باسم البيت الابيض او كانت امراه من اصول
افريقيه طبعا
اول امراه في وزاره
منائبه الرئيس طبعا كاملا هاريس وكانت اول
امراه تحتل منصب وزيره الماليه
اول امراه من اصول يعني اهل او ما يسمى من
الامريكيين من اصول يعني لا مش عربيه قصدي
على الاصول الامريكيه يعني
بسموها كانت وزيره للداخليه وبالتالي
بنلاقي انه هذا الاداره بالضبط هذه
الاداره الديمقراطيه بتمكن الاقليات بدرجه
كبيره كتير وهذه معكوسه على كل المناصب
العاليه حتى بوزاره الخارجيه بوزاره
الدفاع طبعا اول وزير الدفاع من اصول
افريقيه
الى اخره يعني نلاحظ ولفتني انه بعض
الافلام تكون ارفع شاننا ولكن تخسر على
حساب افلام عاديه لانه مواضيعها او شؤونها
لا تخدم اهتمامات هوليود واهتمامات
بالافلام هل يخدم الشان الامريكي تخدم
الشان الامريكي لا اعتقد في فصل بين
السياسه وبين الفن مع احيانا بقولوا الفن
يقلد السياسه والعكس
الواقع لكن الافلام التقليديه الكبيره
اللي هي بتعمل ملايين الدولارات
يعني بالسينما
بتتراجع نوعا معي الاسماء المعروفه اللي
احنا بنعرفها مخرجين ممثلين هوليود عم
تتراجعوا على حساب اشخاص هم يعني اتوا من
خلفيه مختلفه وهذا يعني هذا في له جانب
ايجابي اللي هو بيثري المجتمع الامريكي
على فيلم امريكي بالسوري بتشوفي حالك فيه
يعني اذا في واحده من اصول عربيه انا بشوف
حالي في يعني بتصير تمثلني بتصير السنه
كتير كتير قريبه منك
افلام هوليود يعني اللي كانت دايما فيها
السيريوتايبس خصوصا على العرب او غير
الامريكيين غير الابيض ولا على العرب
بيتهيا لي موضوع كتير طويل يعني يمكن نخصص
حلقه له انه كيف السينما بتعكس الصوره
السلبيه عن العرب بشكل عام لكن اللي
بيغيرها هم الممثلين يعني رامي مالك بتوقع
انه من اصول مصريه وحاز على اوسكار قبل
قبل فتره بيص يروا الناس يهتموا اه هو من
اصل مصري او من اصل لبناني ومن اصل فوزي
فبصير اهتمام بالقوميات بيغير نوعا ما من
الصوره النمطيه لكن بشكل عام اعتقد لسه
قدامنا طريق طويل قبل ما تغير صوره العربي
بامريكا
[ضحك]